كره فضيه بحجم كره البولينج تقريبا تسمى
اورب لاجراء مسح لحدقه العين فبمجرد ان
يتم التحقق من انك انسان حقيقي ولست
روبوتا تصبح لك هويه عالميه ويسمح لك
باستخدام مشروع
العمله الرقميه العالميه شهد المشروع اكثر
من مليوني طلب تسجيل للحصول على الهويه
العالميه خلال فترته التجريبيه
وسيتوسع نطاق العمليات ليشمل 35 مدينه في
20 دوله لكن ما الهدف من اطلاق هذه العمله
الرقميه يقول سام التمان
يمكن ان تساعد في معالجه كيفيه اعاده
تشكيل ملامح الاقتصاد من خلال الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي الامر الذي سيكون له
اثار اقتصاديه هائله ففي عصر بدا التشيع
فيه روبوتات الذكاء التوليدي مثل تشات جي
بي تي التي يمكنها ان تنتج لغه تشبه
الحديث البشري تصبح مساله الهويات
العالميه ضروريه ويعتقد اوتمان ان الدخل
الاساسي العالمي يمكن ان يساعد في مكافحه
غياب المساواه في الدخل مع اطلاع الذكاء
الاصطناعي بالمزيد من الاعمال التي يقوم
بها الان البشر على الرغم من اهدافه
النبيله المعلنه ينظر كثيرون بعين الريبه
للمشروع ويعتبرون انه لا يتمتع بالشفافيه
اللازمه خاصه فيما يتعلق بمصير المعطيات
الشخصيه للمستخدمين هذا الى جانب مشاكل
قانونيه قد تعترضه في دول مثل الولايات
المتحده التي شددت القيود المفروضه على
العملات المشفره